if I lived in Cape Town I'd be doing
exactly this standing in line to collect
water and a jug like this and I'm
allowed up to six gallons for myself
from this spring right here but even
though I'm visiting I'm still expected
to adhere to the water restrictions of
cities and acting in an interview with a
deputy mayor he told me they don't want
to deter tourists because they need the
business they just want them to act like
a local but what does that really mean
I'm gonna show you what it means to live
on 50 liters or 13 gallons of water a
day
when checking into my hotel I was
reminded by the staff that Cape Town is
in the middle of an unprecedented
drought and water shortage so there's a
sign hanging in the shower that says did
you know that a two minute shower uses
approximately 30 litres of water a day
now captain Ian's are restricted to
using only 50 litres of water a day
which is about 13 gallons and just for
some context estimates vary but the
average American uses 80 to 100 gallons
of water a day there's a really nice
bathtub in the room but don't even think
about taking a bath during a water
crisis like this you're not allowed to
in fact the hotel staff have removed the
plug so you can't even fill the tub it
would be a lot of water of course
estimates are about 36 gallons of water
just to fill a full bathtub newer
toilets can use about one and a half
gallons of water per flush but older
ones can use up to four gallons per
flush and there's one message here in
Cape Town that they're constantly
reinforcing and that is it's yellow let
it Mellow so basically the amount of
water that Cape Toni ins are each being
asked to use per day adds up to two hand
washings to teethe brushings a two
minute shower one toilet flush a half
gallon of drinking water and one cooked
meal to get a sense of how locals are
changing their ways I visited Anita and
got a tour of the conservation system
she's implemented in her home when we
shower we catch the water and then use
the water to flush the toilets we don't
flush the toilet if it's yellow but if
it's brown then we do flush the toilet
so two or three times a day maybe this
toilet gets flushed and do it by it's
pouring the water down the toilet like
that and what you even do is when we
turn on the shower you know the first
shower water is cold yes and you're not
standing under it but it's perfectly
good water so I fill up this for the
first shower water and I put it here and
we use that for brushing our teeth over
here and then as the water gets warm we
saw shower we catch that and other
buckets here for the toilet
what's your showering schedule like now
we should sort of sure when we need grey
water so if we're running out of water
to flush the toilet we have a shower but
it works up to sort of once every two or
three days we'll have a proper shower
but very fast and
when we were practicing up with my
husband to time me and I could shard in
45 seconds it takes about a minute if
I'm washing my hair as well but you
learn to stop start your shower prior to
the drought how regularly were you
showering once or twice a day even yeah
how has this changed your perspective on
how we use water well I don't think
we'll ever go back to our old ways I
think I'll always reuse my clothes
though as much as possible because it's
actually fine just just bad habits of
washing things over and over also I
really don't think I've ever flush my
toilet together with beautiful drinking
water you can think for years with we've
been flushing our toilets with beautiful
drinking water you're not the first
person to tell me that when you wash
dishes I use the spring water or cooking
I use the spring water I've bought this
to help rinse dishes it's a
high-pressure hose you still give it a
bit of comfort a few times yeah they do
that and you can rinse dishes
rather than using rather than using the
tap so for dinner we've been eating like
this so eating our food on year and then
after dinner just throwing away the
plate and sometimes we've just wipe the
plate with a weight wipe same goes for
their hands so I've given every member
or family a little bag like this and in
the bag we've got a little mini bag of
wet wipes we've got some tissues and
we've got some waterless hand cleaner
Anita is now also collecting rainwater
what level would you say it's out right
now yeah it's here it's not Hall and if
it gets to this point and a point
municipal water will come in
ideally what level do you want it all
the time when was the last time it was
this high um will our neighbors have
offered us borehole water so what we do
know is I've got a real long hose pipe
from our neighbors neighbor's property
and we bring it across and in and we
fill it up what I also do now is if rain
is forecast I suddenly started using
more water because I want to make space
in my tank people talk about rain as if
we farmers now and it's it's wonderful
this connection we have again with with
nature the earth which I think we lost
in the city everywhere I went in Cape
Town I was reminded to conserve even in
popular tourist areas like the V&A
waterfront here is this fixture in the
middle of the waterfront that says how
will the water crisis affect you you
actually go inside and it's a bit
interactive tell us what you're doing to
save water hashtag water heroes here it
gives you an idea of how much water is
used per activity so laundry use 14
litres cooking 3 liters of water right
there
toilet flushing 9 liters right next to
it saying let it Mellow if it's yellow
of number one and flush it with grey
water so not the clean water so really
everywhere you go in this city you look
up you look down there are reminders
about day zero and urging everyone to
reduce their water usage public
bathrooms don't even give you the option
to waste water all the fixtures of the
six have been removed there are signs
that say that washing hands is
prohibited another sign here pointing
out that due to the drought and water
crisis showers and some taps have been
disconnected instead people are using
hand sanitizer over there some artists
have even created playlists to help you
time your shorter showers it's all part
of a comprehensive effort to save water
that I found myself taking part in like
a local so if I was a resident and I ran
out of my water I'd be back here at this
natural spring at the foot of the
mountain to refill my jugs again this is
how Cape Tony ins are dealing with their
water crisis and their severe drought
and it really makes you reach
how you use water and your relationship
to it every single day and who knows my
city could be next and so could yours hi
guys it's Deena thanks for watching our
series from South Africa make sure to
come back next Tuesday for another video
I'm coming to you from Flint Michigan
where the water crisis here is far from
over
please like share and comment this video
and subscribe to aj+